this is tomorrow same standing in for
reviewer Mike Epstein neo2 is not to be
trifled with building on the originals
tough-as-nails reputation team ninja
second samurai action RPG brings back
the originals partial for punishing and
highly nuanced combat the sequel hones
in on the originals distinctive take on
the souls like without completely
reinventing itself the result is a long
tough slog that will push even the most
challenged hungry players to their
breaking points despite the title neo 2
is a prequel revealing the secret
history of a decades-long period of war
in medieval Japan the story gives just
enough context for you to follow along
and make you feel like you're making
progress without getting in the way of
gameplay with core mechanics refined
from the bones of Dark Souls neo to
balls down to a series of battles and
deals in all kinds of situations these
battles demand intense precision not
only are your attacks and skills limited
by a stamina meter called ki for any
extra attack or mistimed movement will
leave you exposed often to an attack
that will cost you a substantial amount
of health like other souls like games
there's a painful pleasure in mastering
whatever opponents the game throws your
way
neo - builds on the wonderfully diverse
range of options for developing a
personal fighting style the original
systems return and the core weapon
combat remains largely unchanged from
the original beyond some new abilities
and two new weapon types the speedy
two-handed switch clave and really
speedy double hatchets neo 2 demands
that you have profound understanding of
all the attacks your weapons can perform
but there's a wide range of attacks and
they each put their own spin on how you
fight neo twos biggest additions revolve
around the idea that he can channel
yokai spirits the most important is a
hard parry called the burst counter
which allows you to count a powerful
enemy attacks every enemy has at least
one attack that's vulnerable to the
counter they're often big powerful moves
that you'll be tempted to dodge fighting
the urge and throwing yourself at your
enemy to turn the tide of battle for a
moment is crucial which makes the combat
feel more tactical and aggressive in the
moment when you spot an enemy prepping a
burst attack you feel successful like
you've gotten one over on your opponent
even for a second
because the game is so difficult these
little victories help drive you forward
[Music]
you learn yokai abilities by equippable
soul cause that allow you to momentarily
transform into the enemies you've killed
to use one of their attacks more than
ninjutsu and magic which returned from
the original game spirit cause add a
much wider range of contextually useful
skills for example as the monkey yokai
Enki you jump into the air and throw a
spear which is quite novel as neo2
doesn't have a jump on when the yokai
get bigger
sometimes a giant head or fist or foot
magically appears to maim your enemies
they aren't so powerful that you can
lean on them to win a fight but these
skills widely expand the range of things
you can potentially do last but not
least neo - adds a super powerful yokai
shift transformation which temporarily
makes you faster and stronger triggering
the transformation does not eliminate
the need for tactics though you are
invulnerable of using attacks and taking
damage reduce the amount of time you
have in your stronger form a failed
assault in yokai mode not only wastes a
powerful slowly charging asset but may
also leave you unexpectedly exposed if
you revert to your old self because your
opponent caught you off-guard in true
neo fashion even your greatest strength
can become a chance for your enemy to
get the upper hand
learning your own skill set is just part
of the experience to really excel you
also need to understand neo two's wide
world there's an astounding amount of
variety across an extremely long
campaign it's winding multi area
missions span all kinds of environments
from burning castles and temples to
military camps to forests and mountain
sides many of them change radically as
you explore them giving you a sense of
travel and accomplishment for covering
what feels like a long distance one
early level for example starts on a
hillside outside a castle and ends in a
massive underground cave even when the
levels seem similar very design makes
each one feel distinct and worth
conquering it helps that the maps are
more than twisty turny dungeon crawls
most have at least one area with a
unique trap or environmental conundrum
in one forest level for instance a giant
owl youkai patrols certain areas
alerting enemies if it sees you also
there are dark realm zones black and
white areas haunted by yokai that
provide an EVA greater challenge by
slowing down your key generation it's
only by defeating us first
the enemy in a dark room that it will
dispel permanently injecting more ways
for you to make progress that doesn't
reset when you use a shrine or die even
for all its variety neo2 stretches all
of its content as much as it can for
every mission in its core campaign there
are two or three side missions many of
which remix a portion of the story
mission Plus upon finishing the campaign
you'll get access to a difficulty level
with higher-level enemies and gear while
it can be a little annoying in principle
to play the same section of a level
three to four times each version finds
little ways to change your path and
present new challenges to keep things
fresh
likewise neo 2 never seems to run out of
new enemies to throw at you almost every
level has at least one new type of
youkai for you to study and struggle
against each enemy has its own range of
a Balise and you need to learn
everything about them in order to
anticipate their attacks and get the
upper hand the process takes time you
won't get it on the first try or even
after the first victory every enemy can
kill you if you aren't bringing your
a-game dissecting enemy patterns and
figuring out how to counter them is the
sweetest pleasure neo - offers that
there are so many enemies with so many
different attacks to navigate ensures
that the game never loses flavor you see
this most clearly when you go up against
each of the game's extraordinarily
difficult boss encounters like the
levels the bosses vary wildly and are
all sites to behold from a giant snake
with many snake arms to a three-story
spider with a Bulls head each flagship
enemy design has a lot of character and
is unlike anything you've seen in the
game before they all have one thing in
common though they're extremely
difficult even more than standard vowels
the bosses effectively demand perfect
play for an extended period you need to
be able to recognize every move they
make as they make it and know how to
respond instantly very few took me less
than a dozen tries and many of them took
multiple hours at times I wondered if
maybe some of these encounters should be
a little short as there were many bosses
where I felt I had mastered their
pattern but couldn't finish because they
landed a single one hit kill late in the
fight ultimately that excruciating
difficulty and the feeling evokes our
baked into neo twos DNA and his boss
fights remain compelling even as they
vex and frustrate though the difficulty
can sometimes
feel like a curse upon you as you play
it's a testament that neo to
successfully grabs and holds your
complete attention so close for so long
[Music]
[Music]